[Music]
are you really i don't know why i don't
know why from what you said ideas around
correcting things like
what i think would be a great thing is
if we can edit out being an [ __ ]
[Music]
we have to ask where these ideas of
perfection come from and every age and
every society has its own ideas about
what it considers in people desirable
and undesirable it wasn't that long ago
that people considered homosexuality
such a problem that if we could identify
a gay gene they would screen their
children for it and now we find that
abhorrent rightly abhorrent but i you
know where do we draw that line people
say to me
i have had someone say to me
of an older generation i should say you
know how would you feel if you had if
your son was gay um you know would you
rather he was not gay and the slippery
slope of that is well what else would
you rather
not have in your children because it
would make their lives harder me being
brown makes my life harder would i want
to edit that out knowing the society
that i live in of course not but these
ideas about what is desirable and
undesirable what will make your life
easier for your children and not easier
for your children we have to think very
carefully about and the reason why i
said before that i would not want to
edit my son or airbrush my son before he
was born is because i'm a north london
mum and i understand fully what you're
saying we want the best for our children
we give them every opportunity in life
but the question is what are we shooting
for here and what we're shooting for is
society's idea of what success is
success is having a great job doing
really well at school earning loads of
money well what if our our idea of
success is whatever kind of child we
have and whatever their talents they are
happy
with what they have and living the life
that they have
and you know content in whatever skills
and capacities that they have and they
enjoy them
i mean that is the happiness i want for
my son the success i would like for
myself
look i agree with you but i think at the
end of the day this is fine words but
the question is going to be where the
decision point is taken and so far the
way you've been talking is as if you're
going to leave it to individuals to
hopefully in some kind of ethical
framework coming from somewhere we'll
make the right kinds of decisions and
the reason why i bring the state in has
nothing to do with perfectionism or
anything like that but there should be
some kind of uniform policy within which
we can tolera you know we can explicitly
say we tolerate and perhaps even
encourage a certain variety of options
okay i this is what i'm talking about
because at the moment this the state is
not involved at that level to actually
you know articulate this and you're just
hoping the market allows it i'm not
hoping anything of the kind steve for
one thing i don't think we'll be able to
edit in the way that you imagine we'll
be able to edit and um secondly just
because the state is not involved that
doesn't mean there are pressures on
people that are driven by the way
society and culture works but the state
ought to take responsibility i'm kind of
confused a little about why you're
saying the state isn't involved at this
point because
i mean the reality of it now is that
it's been pretty much agreed upon from
regulatory levels in both
the us as well as the uk and other and
the eu that it's unacceptable to make
gene edits that would be considered
enhancement right that they should
really that they should be but that's
going to be overturned i mean isn't that
the premise of this whole discussion
that that kind of idea is going to be
overturned
you don't know that we don't know that
because it because of china basically
well no
but to be clear too it's and then just
so we have this that we're all aware of
this differentiation and there's
therapeutic ideas around correcting
things like
collecting like
that's a [ __ ] distinction that's a
[ __ ] distinction
what we're talking about basically is is
editing the germ line right yeah so that
those same edits then get passed on to
future generations and start changing
the human gene pool and so because of
that i think there is this real
impotence of for justice and collective
decision making because this isn't about
just one set of parents the state
this is about the state i don't know
what you're even saying when you're
saying that anymore i'm confused no no
but that's the state is the locust where
that happens no i understand that i'm
just saying that
well i mean
you you act as if politics doesn't exist
no but no she doesn't actively engage
with
it louder
let people decide but then you're saying
the stages intervene how do these two
things the state organizes the forms in
which the decision making of the sort
you're talking about will occur so it
sets the phase we're saying the same
sorts yes exactly that's why i say we're
in violent agreement
well certainly but it's just that you
hate the word stage i think you're
providing violence no no no no no the
problem is that people who get caught no
because of the history of eugenics which
angela referred to let's also call
eugenics white supremacy like let's call
it no it is that's the point we're
engaging it with gene editing that is
eugenics it's eugenics 2.0 and and the
thing is we need the state once again
involved but in the way you're talking
about and we should own it so you don't
want it to be left just to the
marketplace exactly
well no one i think wants that do you
want no no sure
he's not here
the question of who gets the benefit of
this because i mean one of the things
that people have talked about gene
editing is that it it's another one of
the technologies that people say oh this
will allow us to put off similarity and
live longer
um
and i could see people saying hey i'm a
millionaire i want to live 50 years
longer than anyone else
uh let them all die at 35 and i'll live
to 160.
is that a good thing i mean it's good
for them well that's what i'm saying
what is a good thing really depends on
your perspective what i think would be a
great thing is if we can edit out being
an [ __ ]
yeah i would love that
can we do that i put a lot of people out
of work
why is it always you know
height or
eye color or intelligence you know
because the answer
[Music]
of the technology won't be available to
everyone
oh yeah and and
does that matter
if a technology well it depends so i
think it's yeah no i so but i think what
gets complicated is when we're talking
about non-human applications okay please
there's a much sort of
potentially broader impact of some of
these technologies right so you brought
up this idea of if you could use crispr
and this is these technologies are
developed in labs already to use crispr
to create um
genetically engineered mosquitoes in
order to be released into the wild and
suppress the mosquito species that
transmits malaria
malaria causes almost 500 000 deaths
every year 70 of which are children
it happens to normally impact the most
poor of our of our world
and so
there are a lot of people within these
communities impacted by this disease
that want this technology to be
continued to be developed and so i think
actually on both sides of this black you
know when this argument becomes black or
white like
go full force we need to keep this
technology going and blah blah blah blah
or
we shouldn't even be touching this
technology it's it's too risky it's not
right like both of those are positions
of privilege
you know so saying not to use that
because you're in a in a country where
your children aren't dying from malaria
and you have the choice to how you're
going to find your food and how you're
going to live a really high quality of
life like that's a position of privilege
to say that that technology shouldn't be
used it's also a position of privilege
to say that technology should go
straight ahead and everything's going to
be great because so far technology has
represented your your your status quo in
your world view it's working for you so
why wouldn't you be wary of technology
and so i think that's sort of what we
have to remember is that there's a lot
of privilege being enacted in these
sorts of discussions and how important
is that this is so nuanced and we really
think about you know the middle ground
approach of holding both sort of
both things at once
and that's what the state is for
i'm sorry
i'm sorry that's what the state is for
frankly
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas